chef/owner Thomas Keller has three
michelin-starred restaurants under his
belt and he's likely to garner even more
accolades with his next restaurant
crafted in partnership with related the
real estate development company behind
New York City's Time Warner Center Steve
Ross of course the founder of that and
that's where you going to find per se
one of the best and most expensive
restaurants in America dinner there
starts at three hundred and ten dollars
per person before you even get to the
wine chef Keller gave me a tour in his
kitchen explain a little bit you know
what's going on there well so over here
is our garbage I area so what happens
over here is they're going to do all the
canapes which is a little little bites
that you get in the beginning all the
the salads and then
one of the final savory courses right on
this side here you're going to have hot
canapes with other things like the
oysters and pearls things like the pasta
things like that next to him is the fish
so do all the fish and seafood
preparation across from that is all the
meat preparation next to them is going
to be all all the vegetables or the
entremet TA and of course this is the
pass right here so all the savory food
matthew here's our executive sous chef
so matthew during the night we'll be on
that side in a white apron as well and
he'll he'll orchestrate he'll
orchestrate the entire menu and over
here behind you shares pastry okay so
that's kind of different the different
stations throughout the kitchen yes and
Matthew is preparing to Dover sole and
you're stuffing it with a mousse of is
gonna be a garlic garlic mousse for
tonight's menu that's the fish course
for tonight's menu do you model your
kitchens all around about the same I
mean are they all pretty much well the
French army which you see here which is
actually a temporary kitchen at the
French augury right now oh yeah that's
not the permanent kitchen that's a
temporary kitchen yes but this kitchen
is modeled after was a model dock the
original French Laundry kitchens okay so
it's a little bigger you keep an eye on
the French Laundry kitchen well what we
want to do is have a connection we don't
really have to keep an eye on each other
you want to make sure you want to do is
that connection between you know it's a
cultural connection between the two
teams okay and the restaurants and
understanding and knowing that there's
you know hold another team a whole other
hundred people across the country who
are focused and committed in the same
way
so that that cultural kind of connection
is very important to us now one last
thing I'm always curious about because
look you are a world-renowned chef and
you know people love your restaurant I'm
kind of curious you go to another
restaurant you know what's the first
thing you notice or what's the first
thing you look at you know it's it's
really about the staff and how they're
holding themselves right there their
pride in what they're doing I think is
very important cuz it kind of tells a
lot about restaurant is the pride of the
people in the restaurant and then
certainly just you know I am I'm really
you know a detailed kind of person so
I'm always looking at the you know how
the defcons are folded or how the the
silver is polished or how the glasses or
shine things like that I'll people that
tell you dress yeah that's very
important that tells you how good of an
it kind of gives you a sense of the
about how the the operators are paying
attention to the details cuz it's always
about the details what's your favorite
thing to order tipping remember the chef
wants to give me do you ultimately get
up to now yeah